[Musique]
c'est presque dix ans on a commencé les
premières séries on en a fait 6 et on
parle d'en faire peut-être une septième
bientôt cette fois ci ce alors ce qui
est amusant c'est que les premiers
épisodes des brigades du tigre commence
dans une vieille salle de gym c'est
exact seulement en 1907 on avait trouvé
à orléans une vieille salle de gym qui
étaient intactes quand quoi le sport pas
toujours en progrès et j'en avais trouvé
les agréent tout impact dans cette salle
il ya dix ans comme en 1907 et là vous
êtes et sciences vous étiez censés en
film évidemment à prendre la boxe
française à apprendre la langue
française c'était oui c'était le grand
sport naples et la savate à l'époque
attend on appelle la boxe française
alors je me suis mis à l'occasion de ce
film et puis comme j'en ai fait d'autres
je me suis mis un peu plus sérieusement
et je crois que pour moi la boxe
française c'est un des sports de combat
pour moi le meilleur ça ça dépasse
karaté c'est vraiment un sport
formidable que je les couverts et la
voxan sèche complètement fan s'était
c'est amusant et étonnant à la fois que
la boxe française a autant d'importance
dans les brigades du tigre
oui mais c'était c'était larmes de
l'époque je veux dire c'était encore
l'époque où on avait du style et où il y
avait du panache et où les les policiers
et les truands se rencontrer presqu'à
manu est allé trouver une armée c'était
le boxe française en dehors de la boxe
française mouko sportif du sportif
oui enfin pas de
je me tiens en forme pour faire l'acteur
il faut rester en forme toujours je pars
du sport à haut niveau n'ont jamais j'en
ai fait mais je suis surtout sportif
devant ma télévision qu'on réduit par
des français mais là j'aime beaucoup ça
et moi je suis très admiratif des
sportifs parce que pour moi sont les
acteurs pas d'acteur on va pour moi
l'acteur type c'est un sportif c'était
bien celui qui sait agir et il arrive à
mettre le mouvement à un niveau de
perfection
et c'est dans ce sens là où j'ai très
admiratif des grands sportifs parce que
c'est le mouvement sur la façon de
bouger avec une économie de moyens et
perfection dans le geste qui est
formidable
dans ce sens ça vous pensez par exemple
que les jeux olympiques c'est un
fabuleux terre fabule fabuleux
malheureusement cette année sont prêtés
film et qu'ils arrivent comme ils
auraient dû mais pour moi ces familles
j'attends par exemple des films sur des
décathloniens sur des choses comme ça ça
c'est des gens que qui pour moi sont des
dieux c'est extraordinaire dette
atteignant les gens dont on parle
pratiquement pas
[Musique]